so who cares so if i come to you right
now let's go back
you're the you're a mortgage broker in
long island i meet you in a diner which
is you call your office
the imperial diner of freeport
absolutely phenomenal yeah you go you
got to make it real yeah so it's the
imperial diner in freeport
on merrickrobe yeah you say meet me at
the office and you
i hear you hanging out we'll spill hot
coffee in here by mistake looking and go
yeah yeah and when you tell me to meet
you at your office i hear the clang of a
pay phone when you hang up yeah
and so i meet your office i come in i
say hey how you doing nice to meet you
mr dylan me and my wife just got married
um you know i'm a comedian i i saved up
about 80k
um uh you know she wants to live we're
having a baby she wants to live on the
island you got to pop
i'm very glad can i get a loan not only
can you get along but let me let me
tell you something yeah how much that
80k are you prepared to spend on the
property
i don't know uh mr dillon i you know i'm
pretty conservative guys saved every
single dollar
from my mortgage how much you prepared
to spend um
hold on let me go into maurice's brain
no no of that 80 000 how much would you
like to spend are you willing to spend
all of it
i i'm going to spend i'm willing to
spend about 60 or 70 of it mr poppets
guess how much of that area you're gonna
have to spend how much
nothing what nothing you're not gonna
spend anything because let me explain
something to you
sit down the wife is lovely would you
like a cup of coffee yeah
here's the thing yeah can i get a poppas
can i get pancakes
yeah you can get anything the bricks and
sticks of your house
yeah appreciate the frame the land
they appreciate value you know what your
money does in your house for you mr
pappas
it does absolutely nothing you know what
the wealthiest people do
with real estate mr pappas a lot of them
finance it why
because your mortgage is your only tax
write-off it is the only write-off
is your only [ __ ] weapon against
the federal government the larger the
loan you take
the better it is for you financially and
you take that eighty thousand dollars
and i'm not wrong by the way and you put
while i'm a little and you put it in tax
exempt securities like roth iras
mr pappas you maximize the amount
of of tax exempt retirement accounts
that you put your money in with that 80
000 you make it work for you
you do not sink it into a house yes or
yes
so the reality is this we're taking the
biggest
loan possible mr pappas
will set you free now
sign this piece of paper for christ
and at that point you and your wife are
crying yeah yeah and then uh we sign
papers then you do you go die but how do
you get the loan from the bank
they're giving them away what are we
doing we're talking about now or back in
the day
well back in the day yeah can you go to
bank i said kelly
we got one and kelly i said mr pompous
and his wife brittany's from long island
they want to go buy a piece of marble
hunk of [ __ ]
and kelly has got coke running down her
nose from last night she's got a [ __ ]
double tall non-fat latte from starbucks
non-fat she's not getting anyone
and she knows it down and she says let
me
she makes all the paperwork look like it
should look and then my little shitty
bank which was called
franklin first or new world mortgage or
the mortgage zone or if the funding hut
or whatever it is
we send our paper to a [ __ ] even
bigger and as similarly shitty bank like
a long beach mortgage or a
new century mortgage or an argent and
those banks were doing back door deals
with jp morgan citigroup
so those banks were underwriting the
paper to the to the middle grade banks
that we're lending money to the dirtbag
brokerage
operating out of a van places that i
work
okay right so when it's all you ever
played a game hot potato yeah it's an
orgy yeah
so when so when everything goes wrong
you pass it around
around and by the time you sign your
mortgage by the time you get your first
bill because the other benefit mr pop is
you don't pay for two months
right for two months you don't pay but
are you sure i'm gonna be able to afford
this mortgage
my stand-up comedy career is up and down
mr pappas i've watched your stuff
i think you're a genius thank you and i
think you're absolute genius and i will
tell you this right now
all you have to worry about right now is
is is is what are you going to do with
i'm just a little worried i'm not
passing the seller am i going to have a
future
what you're going to have a seller in
the home that we put you in
all you have to worry about is a pop is
what are you going to do with those two
free months because we're rolling it
into the mortgage you've got 60 days
i would take a little vacation with this
lovely lady are you serious
too because i was concerned i even had
enough for the mortgage before this
two free months what yeah that's right
you're saying free am i gonna have to
pay at some point for this
down the line we're rolling into the
mortgage which again we talked about it
just increases your tax deduction
if you could mr pappas you take a loan
every day honey
every day you would take a loan because
the federal government
is coming to take your hard-earned money
i am telling you
your ability to fight them is contingent
on how big this mortgage is
take all your credit card debt all your
car loans everything student loans
roll it into this refinance it let's
take a hundred thousand dollars 200 000
let's do it let's make it big let's do
it once and do it right
that's a great line that's the line one
of our guys had let's do it once
and do it right and then he called him
back eight months later
and they'd go you said we're gonna do it
once and do it right he goes let's do it
twice
and do it better but that's what we need
that's the only way the economy is
getting like you guys can laugh at that
that's the only way the economy is going
to get
on a bubble honestly you need criminals
back you have to sell things to other
retailers
everything you explained none of that is
criminal at all it's just wow well
i wouldn't go so far i wouldn't say that
yeah no
none of it was criminal i didn't really
do the criminal [ __ ] the criminal [ __ ]
was really
um and it was just i'm a [ __ ] it's not
because of morality the criminal [ __ ]
really was
well we did a little criminal stuff the
lying the people yeah people that would
bring my cousin my cousin
owns a car dealership on uh northern
boulevard is going to say that i've
worked there for the last six years and
maybe 80 grand a year
right look the other way and go let's
approve them for the morning by the way
that's that's kind of soft fraud because
the bank was not it wasn't
fake documents it was literally they
were accepting uh uh
honor system let me ask you this
question how did this orgy get started
is my first question my second question
is
when did you know it was over and my
third question is can you compare it to
stand-up comedy three questions when i
when the origin got started after
um well it started two two places it
started with the community reinvestment
act
under the clinton administration uh a
lot of things that end up being very bad
start with good
positive things and like basically
people are saying you gotta start
communicating like communism right you
gotta start expanding lending in
minority communities and uh low-income
communities you gotta expand
opportunities to credit
people need to be able to finance things
get into the american system
they don't have that opportunity they're
denied by banks all the time they we
need to stop that
so community reinvestment act planted
the seeds in the heads of
wall street people and financial uh
industry executives
that they needed to come up with
products that allowed them to lend
to traditionally riskier borrowers
borrowers that might have had less
income
less credit less less you know uh
whatever um
um and so what then happened was after 9
11
the economy was in a recession and alan
greenspan you know
they cut rates fed cut rates uh and
then then the party started where it was
like now it was like
hey get get in let's let's kick start
the economy yeah we're gonna get lunch
yeah we gotta get some houses going on
and then it was a a real estate boom a
construction boom
um all of these exotic financial
products that allow you to pay one or
two percent
like a credit card that's all payment
that's on the way
sure some version of that will be on the
way on those financial products within
bundled up
and sold uh to uh investment
funds and then people and this is we're
so interconnected we're really [ __ ]
everything was like
people's pensions were tied into these
funds that were
wrapped up with very toxic assets which
was the term
which was bad mortgages mortgages given
to people that had no ability to repay
them
uh and that's the mortgage-backed
security which was invented by a guy
named lou rainery
uh who's profiled in the big short that
was when they decided
that mortgages should be traded and sold
between banks and investment
uh institutions like stocks your bank
used to hold your mortgage so
early on you would go to a mortgage bank
and you would have the bank
i mean so many scenes in old movies are
a guy arguing with the banker it's been
rough this month it's the banker that
gave him the mortgage he knew the guy
it was a very localized thing i know him
i know his farm i've been to his farm
i know what he brings in um and then
everything got very global where like i
would give you a mortgage and sell it to
giannis and then y'all just would sell
it to pimp
and then pimp would sell it to shelter
the chocolates would sell your chase
would sell your mortgage to fannie mae
something yeah fannie mae and freddie
mac or gsc's are government-sponsored
entities meaning they're not technically
government-controlled but they're
government-sponsored meaning the
government
fannie mae and freddie mac are
essentially why we have um
you know some stability in the in the
mortgage market meaning that
they back the loans they
not explicitly but they they ensure
that these loans are good and they
protect banks uh who issue these loans
and fannie mae and freddie uh mack are
well you know one of the reasons you
have a 30-year mortgage you have a
stability over
30 years as a financial instrument
that's kind of unheard of and it's not
common everywhere in the world it's very
uncommon i mean a lot of places there's
only 10-year notes
a 30-year fixed note is is is a
financial product once you work in
europe this is why like the libertarians
and stuff when they start talking about
like
oh the government the government's
always been involved in everything
yeah the government's allowed all of
this to happen so this idea that like
you can uncouple from the government
uh is just not realistic it might have
been it might i'll give them this
it might have been better to not have
the government do all of these things
sure academically great but the reality
is
even just looking at the mortgage market
the reason and the real great book if
anyone has an interest in this
is written by bethany mclean and it's
called all the devils are here
and it's about a sh it's from a great
shakespeare play all the devils are here
she said
bethany mclean also wrote one of the
most influential articles she's a
reporter a reporter
for fortune and she wrote one of the
most influential
articles that's ever been written in
finance and it was called how does enron
make its money
and it was uh the first article that
kind of pierced the
facade of the enron so that book all the
devils are here
is about what you're about the mortgage
crisis depends on who you
blame more here's what it is was there
is it was it more predatory lending it's
like joan rivers said on an episode of
louis know when you're lucky
yeah know when you're lucky there's this
idea
of of and our economy is built on this
model of perpetual growth
right everything's got to be bigger and
bigger and bigger the house has got to
be bigger
the pool's got to be deeper the yard has
got to be bigger the debt is going to be
bigger
you got to know when to hand you got to
know when you got to know when to cash
in it's the disease of more
right the disease of more right and it's
and it was those wall street guys
weren't poor
before they started slinging these
things they weren't poor but they got
you know in the last 10 or 15 20 years
people in that line of work have gotten
astronomically
wealthy a level of wealthy that most
people don't understand
i'm talking about many of them are
earning a billion
dollars in a calendar year or over a
hundred million dollars in a calendar
year right not 30 million not a million
a month not 2 million a month not 5
million a month
we're talking in cases 20 30 million
dollars a month the guys at the top of
those institutions
they've become so [ __ ]
like dislocated from the city there is a
real
[ __ ] like you know problem
with that type of money so on the
deepest level
it was the disease of more on the side
of those who were
getting the loans and on the side of the
people who were giving the law correct
right it's all across the board it's the
american dream
and i knew it was over when i was in a
diner in the same diner i said to the
waiter i said um
hey you know my order at the diner is
always mozzarella sticks
also i'd like a grilled cheese with
turkey because i'm i'm turning over
noodles and then i asked the waitress
where's the closest car
valve yeah grilled cheese with turkey
tomato i'm turning over new leaf i
didn't say bacon i'd say turkey
now let me ask you a question if bacon
goes in the sandwich
with the turkey
[Laughter]
[Music]
coleslaw french fries lightly cooked but
don't burn them don't give me the don't
give me the excuse that people aren't
paying attention in there
so and uh so i said uh
i say to the waiter he goes what do you
guys do i said i do mortgages he goes
what a coincidence i do mortgages
and then the guy who's handed me my
mozzarella sticks took out a card from
his top pocket and put it on the diner
table
and that's kind of the way i felt you
know about a year or year and a half ago
in comedy when
everyone you knew was it met was a
comedian yeah the problem is
yeah when everybody like it's the
secrets out
it's like you know you ever go to a good
restaurant so that's when you knew it
was over when
everyone was getting in yeah well yeah
when it got
which i don't talk to about food a lot a
rush you go to a good restaurant
it's great then you cruise by it on a
saturday night and it's
jammed and you go i hope
in a year from now we don't end up going
back and when this place sucks but a lot
of times that happens
a lot of times when it's the secret
place and they're on the come-up they're
on the rise
everything's great but when it explodes
and everybody's in and everybody's got
their hand in the trough
then all the sudden people start making
stupid decisions they start making bad
decisions
and the people start making decisions
that are nowhere near the actual
decisions
which is why communism all these isms
don't work
is because people are making decisions
from 30 000 feet
about disciplines they have no [ __ ]
idea about how they actually
work right right so when the government
just goes hey
find a way to lend to low-income people
and wall street goes
we got it the government has no idea
what's about to happen
right and then the ones that kind of
have an inkling just keep their mouth
shut because things are good bush goes
70 of americans own homes trump has done
nothing
but extend what obama did which is
extend what bush did
which is essentially just tell people to
put it all on a credit card
that's just the whole thing the economy
is just on the card
we'll think about it later i muyo what
is it 20 trillion
point it's you you don't there's a
number now you can't even say the number
anymore there's not it's yeah it's not
it's got to
think of a new word in the english
language yeah describe the amount the
economy is just on the card it's
on layaway it's like you know what is
that interest rates
what happens when that culminates where
does that end as all things and
what happens how do we reconcile i mean
inflation is where it ultimately leads
to
the devaluing of the dollar the dollar
not being the world's reserve currency
our our debt rating getting trashed
we're not a good debtor anymore so that
means we're over as an empire
yeah triple a bond rating and all that
yeah that's where it leads and then it
just leads
what you're talking about there is the
actual rotting of the infrastructure of
them correct
yeah correct that's enough our inability
to service our debt our inability to
you know basically print the kind of
money that we've been printing to keep
everybody
off the streets which hasn't worked this
is when you become a bad earner in the
mafia and yeah
and you get whacked you can become a bad
earner yeah
right now yeah better we got a lot of
when somebody in the mafia movie starts
looking at a picture of you from the
good times with the sadness
yeah yeah you know they take a picture
they look at you when you guys all went
to like aruba and you went
yeah that was fun he used to that's
where we're at that's where we're
getting today we've got a lot of debts
now
we don't know how to really get them out
but i i think business is common it
could be weed it could be prostitution
i think you got to legalize weed
legalize prostitution day one of biden
or trump's new administration [ __ ] are
in wheat is in
we do not have a job don't
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild